معنا من غلاف غزه مراسله الجزيره نجوان
سمري من حيث انت نجوان ما الذي يمكن رصده
من هذه الطلعات الجويه او حتى القصف
المدفعي الذي يطال مناطق مختلفه في
القطاع نعم محمد اللافت هذا اليوم هي
الغارات المتكرره وال المتتاليه على مناطق
في وسط وشرق مدينه غزه تحديدا وربما
اللافت هو عوده سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
لتنفيذ غارات وعمليات قصف من الجو بعد ان
كانت توقفت نوعا ما او قياسا
بالمرحله السابقه في هذه الحرب على هذه
المناطق وربما لذلك علاقه ايضا
بالانتقادات التي وجهت للسلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي قبل اعاده انتشار القوات في
المناطق الشماليه لانه في واحده من ال
المرات قتل احد جنود جيش الاحتلال في غار
نفذها سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي وربما الان
يعود ايضا هذا هذه الطائرات الحربيه
للمشاركه في عمليات القصف التي عمليا لا
تتوقف صباح هذا اليوم كنا في المناطق
المقابله للمناطق الشماليه من قطاع غزه
منطقه بيت حنون وبيت لاهيا وايضا اطراف
جباليا وشهدنا ايضا على عمليات قصف مدفعي
متواصل استهدفت مواقع عده ويوم امس ايضا
كان هذا القصف المدفعي عنيف بشكل لافت
ومره اخرى عندما نتحدث عن هذه العمليات
نحن نقيسها الى ال ربما الاسبوعين
الماضيين عندما كان هناك نوع من التراجع
في هذه العمليات للقصف سواء كان من البر
او من ال الجو بعد ان اعلن في حينه الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن انه اعاد انتشار وتموضع ل
قواته تحديدا من اقصى الشمال حتى مناطق
الوسط جنوب مدينه غزه تحديدا لكن ربما هو
يواصل عملياته
بشكل او باخر بشكل مختلف هو يتحدث عن
مداهمات وعمليات محدوده ومحدده الاهداف
لكن وتيرتها من الواضح بانها تشتد في بعض
الاحيان وتتراجع في احيان اخرى وفقا
للاهداف التي يقوم
باستهدافها لكن ايضا هناك من يقول بانه في
بعض الاحيان يحاول ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي
بشكل او باخر ال خداع ربما المقاومه
الفلسطينيه من خلال انسحابه من بعض
المواقع ليعود عناصر المقاومه ويتم
استهدافهم مجددا من قبل قوات الاحتلال الا
الاسرائيلي حاليا نسمع ايضا اشتباكات
بالرشاشات الثقيله تاتي تحديدا من جهه شرق
جباليا م محمد ونسمع ايضا قصفا مدفعيا
يستهدف مواقع جنوب مدينه غزه اذا اشتباكات
بالرشاشات الثقيله الان في المناطق
الشرقيه الشماليه لمدينه غزه وايضا قصف
مدفعي يستهدف احياء في جنوب المدينه سنبقى
معك في المتابعه على وقع هذه الصور من
الغلاف شكرا جزيلا لك نجوان سم